so in this week's magazine I interviewed
John Pradas he was ever Miliband's
policy chief he's now back on the back
benches and is quite keen to think about
how labor can rebuild itself after what
he says it's one of the greatest crises
in his history
so John crud ass thinks that Labour's
crisis isn't to do with who its elected
leader it's actually to do with its
identity what does labour stand for
today he recognizes that its membership
has changed a great deal and from the
analysis he's done of the wider
electorate and why it didn't backed
labor in Metis he says that Labour's
membership has drawn just mainly from
her group of voters called the pioneers
who are quite forward-looking
metropolitan socially liberal and not so
much from the prospectors or the
settlers who are other groups of voters
who are either sort of aspirational or
conservative with a small sea
for John quad asked the election of
Jeremy Corbyn is just a symptom of the
problems that Labour has and he's
setting up his own organization to work
on the renewal of labour in the same way
as new labour developed in the early 90s
so that the party could win in the 1997
election he wants to do the same with
his organisation which will involve MPs
from across the party and local
government leaders as well you could
probably see this as potentially a
platform that someone who wants to
become leader after Jeremy Corbyn could
build on but crota's just wants it to be
something that can start right away
as Jeremy Corbyn is getting settled in
as leader for him the leader is
incidental to the problems at the party
phases